على سطح اكثر البحار المتنازع عليها حرب
بارده بين بكين وحلفاء واشنطن لم تتغير
حرارتها جو ملبد بالمخاوف ساد بعد اقتراب
سفينتين واحده صينيه واخرى فلبينيه من
الاصطدام مؤخرا وكاد ان يشعل حربا في بحر
الصين الجنوبي الامر الذي زاد من حاله
القلق لدى بحاره خفر السواحل الفلبينيه
الذين يواجهون العزله والمشاكل اللوجستيه
وسط المحيط ففي دورياتهم عيون تترقب
ورادارات ترصد اي تحرك محتمل الفلبين ترسل
دوريات منتظمه لتاكيد مطالبتها بالجزر
واكتشاف التعديات بالاضافه لاعاده امداد
البحاره الفلبينيين
سياسيا بين مانيلا وواشنطن اصبحت العلاقات
اقوى فالزياره الاولى التي يقوم بها
الرئيس الفلبيني للبيت الابيض خرجت
بتطمينات من الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
لناظره
الفلبينير اما تايوان في قلب القضيه ايضا
وزير الخارجيه التايواني اشار الى تكثيف
الصين تدريباتها العسكريه مؤكدا ان بلاده
ستدافع عن نفسها دون مطالبه دول اخرى
بالقتال من اجلها
التدريبات العسكريه الصينيه الاخيره عبر
مضيقت تايوان يبدو انها مكثفه الى حد ما
وسيقوم الصينيون بارسال الكثير من
الطائرات الحربيه لعبور الخط الاوسط لمضيق
تايوان عام 2027 هو عام مثير للاهتمام
وهذا ما قاله القاده الصينيون لان عندها
سيكون لديه القدره الكامله لشن حرب ضد
تايوان ويصادف ان يكون هذا العام هو العام
الذي سيتولى فيه شين جينج الولايات
الرابعه
احتمال نشوب صراع في السنوات المقبله جعل
واشنطن تعزز وجودها في اسيا اكثر وجعل
الصين على اهبه الاستعداد لاي مواجهه
قادمه اياد حمود العربيه